sobre la isla japonesa de hokkaido una
bola de fuego en el cielo nocturno
transmitidas por la televisión japonesa
estas imágenes muestran un misil lanzado
por Corea del Norte El sábado fue Corea
del Sur quien inicialmente emitió la
alerta y Corea del Norte solo confirmó
el lanzamiento al día siguiente según
Tokio el misil recorrido 900 kilómetros
antes de aterrizar en la zona económica
exclusiva de Japón
el lanzamiento es una provocación cada
vez mayor contra la comunidad
internacional en su conjunto y
naturalmente presentamos una severa
protesta en su contra
la seguridad y la protección de Los
japoneses es la cosa más importante
sobre cualquier otra
las autoridades japonesas afirmaron que
el objeto lanzado era un misil balístico
intercontinental según los expertos
pyongyang quería probar un misil con
combustible sólido una forma de
tecnología que el régimen de Corea del
Norte ha estado tratando de dominar ya
que es más fácil de almacenar y más
difícil de detectar es el segundo misil
norcoreano que aterriza en la zona
económica exclusiva de Japón desde
noviembre de 2022 las tensiones en la
región han ido en aumento en los últimos
meses con un número cada vez mayor en
los ejercicios con misiles de Corea del
Norte y a cambio maniobras militares
conjuntas de seúl y Estados Unidos
el lanzamiento del sábado sigue a varios
días de ejercicios de simulación entre
estos dos aliados Corea del Norte
amenazó con convertir el Pacífico en un
campo de tiro